how do I stay inspired and continue to
show up on my platform and aside from
letting the music speak for it how do I
continue to show up on the platform
meaning what content should you be
putting out or how do you stay inspired
to put out how do I stay inspired by not
beating yourself up when you're not
inspired
you understand yeah that's the part that
people up you'll have plenty of
inspirational days it's when you know
and you don't post you can't go into it
it's kind of like when you're doing well
with your health and you have a bad day
eating that's okay just start picking it
up the next day so if you're not
inspired to post for a week or a month
that's okay but I think people beat
themselves up for that but how do you
continue to make sure that your audience
is engaged or how do you the audience
May decline a little bit but you can't
force it like do you understand yeah
like yes your audience May decline a
little bit if you're styling for three
or four weeks by one percent two percent
but what's the alternative you're gonna
post for the sake of posting you're
better off protecting yourself than the
algorithm